une vraie loi climat c'est ce que
réclament les onze associations
syndicats élus locaux et citoyens qui se
sont réunis la veille du passage du
projet de loi climat et résilience
devant le sénat la loi telle que l a été
remanié par le gouvernement on est tout
juste capable de maintenir les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre au niveau actuel
alors qu'on doit être à moins 55% selon
l'europe et on n'a pas encore ce courage
politique
alors que quand on voit là les citoyens
sont prêts en réalité des situations
beaucoup plus en avance que que les
politiques pour tous le travail de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat n'a
pas été suffisamment prises en compte
dans cette loi il faut impérativement
s'engager fermement sur des vraies
mesures feraient propositions et la
convention citoyenne pour le climat l'a
très bien fait a très bien travaillé
pendant neuf mois auprès de d'experts
150 citoyens de la convention citoyenne
ont émis des voeux et très peu ont été
pris dans le très peu dur d'être pris
dans la loi climat pour les manifestants
qui réclament une audience au président
du sénat gérard larcher deux points
majeurs doivent être modifiés dans ce
projet de loin le terme et coxyde
c'est un crime descossy n'est pas un
délit d' écocide c'est très important
puisque les les réparations pour les
yeux humains sont pas les mêmes et puis
aussi le terme garantir qui est très
important d'un point de vue légal plutôt
que le verbe agir qui n'est pas assez
fort le lundi 10 mai 2021 le sénat a
adopté avec modifications le projet de
loi constitutionnelle relatif à la
préservation de l'environnement